nothing in the entirety of
counter-strike is as sleek
satisfying and downright sublime
as a one tap they gotta go for the plan
there's no one there to interrupt them
just yet so at least they'll succeed but
they need to win this oh my lord faith
what are you doing
second player peeks into the connector
and a nice bait on the site from order
nico
two shots and two kills oh nico has to
watch out he knew that there
there was a player up here towards the
end oh my god excellent what is wrong
with you
a successful one tap is a sign of both
confidence
and disrespect a way to square up with
one's opponent
stare straight into their goddamn soul
and convey the
simplest of messages sit the
[ __ ] down them alone and he almost took
down two that is a ridiculous shot do
they really want to chase him
he seems to be in a position he's taking
him down
yeah he can't believe it and for the
vast majority of players that's all that
one tapping is
a flashy way of asserting mechanical
dominance
but for one belgian aim god it is a way
of
life see there is no player whose one
taps are more
talked about than the edge shot machine
and scream has no armor 41 hp
aim punch significant any not peaking
sponsor right away that is the scream we
know
the crazy thing is that despite being
the single most mythical mug clicker in
the history of counter strike a deal
scream benner litom has spent nearly a
decade
struggling to become the superstar he
was destined to be
throughout scream's career he's faced
gut-wrenching kicks
being the target of scathing criticism
he is also one of the most
one-dimensional star players that have
ever played counter-strike
and he's kind of devolved into a meme
what can i say
they know me for my one top
and yet in spite of it all scream
remains one of the most explosive
adored and mythologized aimers
counter-strike has ever seen
so they have to tap and bait and cold
solo on hp they line up screams got both
that's god like from scream so why is
his professional career seemingly
gone off the rails
okay so aside from being one of the most
drop-dead
gorgeous men in all of esports how did
screen become
the king of spank bank plays well
like kenny and shocks the belgian
prodigy began making a name for himself
in counter-strike
source where he quickly established
himself as one of french cs's
single most explosive talents oh
fragmasters looking strong
1v4 now scream is a big job on his hands
he gets one onto it said he gets another
one that's three
screams spamming away neil doesn't get
the defuse and scream
the beast by the time he'd made the move
to see us go
scream had already become a legend on
the servers but
not because he was a prodigious opera a
master of utility or
had an especially acute game sense no
what scream did have was a very special
set of skills
skills he'd acquired after years of
grinding death match servers
skills that made him a nightmare for
people who enjoyed taking face-to-face
gun fights
a little bit messy in the ct size three
players are trying to spray through one
another doing a bit of damage to
each other but here comes scream with
his ak they need to be careful they
don't face him one at a time we know
what his name is like good scream
oh scream what a nice play you monster
day in and day out this dude religiously
obsessed over one thing
and one thing only if you
flashed him flanked him smoked him off
or threw a molly his way he really
wouldn't be able to do very much
but if you ever decided to challenge him
in any sort of aim duel
he would absolutely [ __ ] destroy you
there's the response as well molotov
gonna go out try and force them out of
position no one has any
a reason to peek but he starts to make
it work scots gets the second frag
thirty seconds left on the clock as
scream
will push his way in he's a bit of a
killer kalashnikov as he makes an
absolute meal out of the round
takes down snatchy can he find the last
one clears the angle noses location
scream gets it
that's where those upsets come from
because early on they did play the
opponents were being that passive style
but now you can see
scream doesn't care anymore screams
doing the no respect for quick hex shots
and the ace
that's beautifully done that is sick
over the years scream has assembled a
portfolio of highlights that have
cemented him as one of the most
unbelievable aimers counter strike has
ever seen
vice versa smith sends him straight to
hell and i'm really pleased about that
scream just
look at these headshots it's
disgustingly beautiful to watch this
guy's aim is ridiculous i don't care
it's against an eco he even had a mouse
made in his honor
you know that weird swiss cheese looking
dongle that final mouse made in
partnership with ninja
yeah i bet none of you the [ __ ] you say
to me little shits knew that they made
one with screamy first
they talk about my one taps and i think
for me
aiming is so easy when i sit down to
play
everything already is a part of me the
crazy thing is that it wasn't just his
inhuman mechanics it was his sky-high
confidence that let's scream dish out
some seriously
big dick plays surely they have to take
this aside before the rotations come in
guardian gets rpk that's their last hope
toward long and it's scream on a fast
rotate that's able to at least get one
now two
but bombs already played they didn't
scream again he's gonna get another it's
just him left though because seized has
found existence but we
there's nothing they can do what a round
from screams and he wasn't just dunking
on random scrubs online
he was making pros who dedicated their
lives to counter-strike
look like absolute bots there's a pop
flash interpol allowing scream to face
at the same time
easy for the screen very patient
bursting and that is uh
a brief anti-eco ace and did i mention
his
pornographic one taps they're better
side it's their t-side where they really
struggle
and scream the only man left comes
around the corner finds a head
on to edward gets himself an ak now oh
my word that was dirty for sure
yeah he's got one bullet in it he's
three legs got one bullet oh
scream quite a big tell when they're oh
my god scream
scream oh show me your sex face
jesus like scream
how could you do them like that these
guys have families
anyway despite being hailed as a dome
smashing divinity
screams actually had one of the most
tragic careers in the history of
counter-strike
after a promising start with very games
that saw him finish
top four at the first ever major nearly
every subsequent major
appearance he's made has been a
certified disaster
on top of that scream has struggled to
find a home over the years
having been kicked from basically every
french oregon existence
what would you like to achieve in cs go
before you'd be happy retiring
i i think i would i would like to have a
team before retiring
i would like to have a team and just
that small steps but
the first step having team yeah that's
just so sad
and maybe worst of all he's been made
the subject of some
pretty cringy caricatures you want me to
tell you a story i would okay i tell
you the scream he is so [ __ ] good
with that shot
you're like oh my god this machine
okay so what exactly went wrong for
screen
well the problem is that his blessing
was also his curse he'd become so
fixated on landing these insane one in a
million headshots
that nearly every other aspect of his
game fell by the wayside
i should teach you some some more of my
friends
and it's it's hit it's hit like it's
like [ __ ] my friend he was basically the
esports equivalent of a bodybuilder who
only works out his arms
and that's a major hindrance in a deep
multi-faceted game like counter-strike
where
you can't always one-tap your way to
victory ultimately you could say that
scream became counter-strike's
definitive example
of all aim no brain
[Music]
still have the full buy from sk so this
round is not over just yet
very likely that state could break this
back and we end up oh my god stream
how do you mess that up he's a perfect
angle on bolts both these teams were
expected to go through
both these teams mentally would have
expected to go through
what happened at the beginning of that
round for envious uh
well because uh on this strategy i
actually need two flashes
okay but i didn't had like two flashes i
had
like four nades so i had to throw the
nade uh but
i didn't expect that and i didn't know
what to say to be honest because like
i mean
before long scream went from a beloved
french superstar to nothing more than a
habitual stand-in
an unknown quantity that teams would
only take a chance on
in truly dire straits but as
disappointing as that may be it's safe
to say that scream's journey wasn't
all for naught these days he's
blossoming as a content creator and it's
almost entirely due to the fact that
he's been able to
lean into his reputation as well a
one-trick
to build a brand around his oh so
recognizable obsession
and who knows maybe it isn't too late
for him to make a comeback
he's only 25 years old he hasn't retired
and he's sure his
[ __ ] isn't washed
so [ __ ] easy man but even if he
doesn't reach those heights as a pro
he'll always have a place in the annals
of counter-strike history
few have inspired as much hilarity well
mythology and love a screaming he may
not be a major winner but
damn if he didn't play a pivotal role in
shaping the culture of counter-strike as
we know it
stare straight into their goddamn soul
and convey the simplest of messages
sit the [ __ ] down
yeah that's good i like that no it's
kind of like the same one i'm just dying
with the game
with the skinny mic
sit the [ __ ] down